for the first time a student who
allegedly benefited from the massive
College Admission scandal is speaking
out the son of Fame marketing executive
Jane Buckingham told The Hollywood
Reporter quote I am upset that I was
unknowingly involved in a large scheme
that helps give kids who may not work as
hard as others an advantage the scam
allegedly helps students get into eight
top universities through cheating and
bribery USC in Los Angeles is one of
those schools Carter Evans is there and
joins us more on this story Carter a lot
of people saying what were they thinking
good morning to you a lot of people
shocked by this and there are a growing
number of apologies and resignations in
the wake of this scandal at the same
time actress Lorie locked in she's from
full house
she's one of the parents charged in the
scandal well she appeared before a
federal judge Lourie Lachlan was
released on a million dollar bond
Wednesday and is due back in court later
this month now remember just be yourself
and talk to me like you would at home
she and her husband Massimo Jian uli
along with actress Felicity Huffman are
among dozens of parents charged in
connection with the estimated 25 million
dollar college admissions scheme run by
William singer hedge fund CEO Manuel and
Rica's also arrested stepped down from
his position at Hercules capital
Wednesday according to court documents
he and his wife paid singer roughly half
a million dollars to help their two
daughters his oldest who was admitted to
Georgetown gloated about having a
proctor sit side by side with her at the
SATs and correct her answers I don't
think that she belongs here because she
never deserved to get in Jane Buckingham
founder of her brand strategy firm is
accused of paying fifty thousand dollars
for a proctor to take the a CT test in
place of her son Jack Jack tells The
Hollywood Reporter I've been advised not
to speak on the matter but I take
comfort in the fact that this might help
finally cut down on money and wealth
being such a heavy factor in College
Admissions mark Riedel whom singer
called his best test taker faces charges
related to fraud and money laundering in
a new statement he apologized saying I
understand how my actions contributed to
a loss of trust in the college
admissions process I just want there to
be a system that's fair to
everyone UCLA student Stephanie Patras
says it will take drastic actions to
level the playing field what would you
like to see the school do about all this
it would be fair for them to get their
admission revoked just because it's like
it shows you that the school is for
integrity here at USC officials say
they're reviewing each student
associated with the alleged scheme on a
case-by-case basis but those implicated
who applied for next year well they will
be denied
JOHN CARTER thank you so much
extraordinary